Jim Bon Temps works for the mothership
and he covers the NBA former Washington
Post New York Post writer his most
recent article how the NBA Draft sets up
a league altering free agency Tim thanks
for joining us I mentioned right after
the draft why don't we have the draft
before a free agency before the draft
how would that change things in the NBA
well then I think what you would see is
a lot of these you know trades that we
have going on now like for example the
pelicans Hawks trade right they trade
Solomon Hill to clear an extra 13
million in cap space along with you know
moving the number four pick that sets
them up to sign somebody to a max
contract and Fred's right now we don't
know who right if they made that trade
you know before free agency then they
just go sign that guy and then later
they go to the draft and they draft
somebody so in one respect we wouldn't
have all these kids going up there and
being drafted by the Lakers DeAndre
hunter goes up there gets drafted by the
Lakers when I picked up a trade twice
and is gonna actually go to Atlanta
right so some of that would go away and
also you would have the ability for
these teams they would go out and free
it see they'd get their guys and then
they come to the draft they've know what
their team looks like and then it could
drop you know based off of whatever the
rest of their team is set up as might be
the final thing their summer I don't
really think this matters that much in
the end because you still have some of
the same issues that happen now like
you'd have teams and dropping for need
instead of Jackie that's player
available and that kind of stuff button
it would definitely make the summer look
a lot different if they did switch it
around go over the free agents schedule
what what happens first here give me the
dates times so I'm so usually in the
past freed see started at midnight on
July 1st this year it's changed it's now
gonna start at 6:00 p.m. on Sunday June
30th which the league did because it was
insane to have everything start at
midnight and have these beatings at 12
o'clock at night and ask people doing
stuff to 4 o'clock in the morning so now
it's going to start at 6 p.m.
and then for the first six days of July
nothing is official which is why we had
the DeAndre Jordan back out and go back
to the Clippers thing a few years ago
and it's called to leave moratorium when
the league does all its accounting and
then July 6th then all the stuff that's
agreed to is officially you know signed
into action so then all the guys sign
their contracts and all the trades are
executed stuff so that's why you'll see
on June on July 6th all the stuff will
happen all at once but that's the that's
kind of a basic breakdown of the way
this will shake out next week what's the
first domino here what player it's kind
of hard to know what the first domino is
because there are so many teams that
have a lot of caps bases here but I
think the most important one is Kawhi
Leonard you know coming into the summer
I thought there were three guys who were
head and shoulders above everybody else
in terms of talent and this free agency
class which is klay Thompson Kevin
Durant and Kawhi Leonard unfortunately
two of them got injured for all of next
season basically in the NBA Finals
so that leaves Kawhi Leonard as the one
guy who can change teams and really make
an impact I think to me he's kind of the
kingmaker of the summer and off next
season because I think he's either gonna
stay in Toronto which if he does they're
you know at least you know the co
favorites to get out of the East to
potentially win another title and or
he's gonna go to the Clippers in the
Western Conference and if he goes there
with the amount of talent they have
around him I think they're arguably the
favorites to get out of the West and go
to the finals and it really isn't
another guy on the market now especially
with Kevin Durant and klay Thompson hurt
that can change the landscape like that
so I think collides decision is the most
important one because it's gonna have a
huge impact on you know where the league
looks going in the next season and what
teams are gonna be favored to make it to
the NBA Finals
do you think this is a question that the
Lakers are mulling D'Angelo Russell
Kyrie or Kemba I'm not sure what the
Lakers are mulling at this point they
could go in many directions I mean I'm
sure they are thinking about that you
know their their situation is so fluid
they can either have about 23 million
space they could have enough to sign a
max player we have to wait and see if
they can maneuver things for that to
work out they then have to figure out
how they're going to fill out their
roster you know everybody is kind of
talking about well this Lakers team is
going to be a dream team well yes they
have LeBron James Anthony Davis and
that's a pretty damn good place to start
however they basically have no one else
on their roster and to your point
they're either gonna be able to sign one
guy like that or a couple of like
moderate players like say Patrick
Beverley and Danny Green and then they
basically have no money left and they
have to go fill in the rest of their
team with essentially minimum salary
guys so you know I would be curious to
see if they did go sign well those guys
I mean look if they sign Kyrie Irving
say right you know they reunited with
LeBron James out with Anthony Davis
that's a hell of a starting three guys
to go with but if you go back to say the
first team that LeBron was on in Miami
you know that team had you know Erick
Dampier Mike Debbie Mike maybe Carlos
Arroyo Joel Anthony may had a lot of
guys who were not very good they were
playing a lot of minutes on that team
now it was a 26 year old LeBron I think
asking a 35 year old LeBron to play on a
team that's that thin you know the
Lakers could be asking themselves for
some trouble next season Kevin Durant's
options are what and what is his reality
do you think how does this play out well
to be honest Dan I don't think his
reality is much different than what it
was before he got hurt other than that
he's gonna miss next year and I say that
when I say that I mean that I don't
think his market is going to change I
think all the teams that were going to
pay him or be willing to pay him are
still going to pay him a max I think
they'll Doris law firm a five year match
just don't think you know the Knicks and
the other teams are interested in will
still offer him a four-year max and you
know he's obviously gonna miss next
season but I still think all the seeds
will take a chance on signing him and
and frankly I don't even think it will
really change his whatever his a
decision was going to be um because
again like he's made I don't even know
probably three hundred million dollars
when you factor in his shoe do I think
he signed a 300 million dollar shoe deal
a few years ago with Nike
he's already signed you know is that
he's already signed a bunch of you know
30 40
dollar contracts right so I think he's
gonna choose wherever he decides he
wants to go based off of the same
calculus she was going to before because
again he's gonna miss next season but
then he'll play the next three and even
if he's eighty eighty-five percent of
the guy he was before the injury that's
still better than just about everybody
in the league so I would think you know
if I was one of these teams I would just
sign him to the same deal I was going to
and just get him for three years instead
of four and I I think that that is how
you know most of these teams are looking
at it obviously you want to bring him
him and look at him but I still think
that you know given where the league is
if you get a chance to sign Kevin Durant
you take the chance on your sire he's
Tim Bon Temps he covers the NBA for ESPN
used to work at the Washington Post New
York Post we have the NBA awards coming
up tonight why are we giving out these
words I mean come on this is for the
regular season and it's just so after
the fact literally figuratively I mean
it's it's silly yeah it's very silly
basically it was done because the NBA
when they they signed their new massive
TV deal was TNT and ESPN TNT wanted
another thing to broadcast I think so
now they have this thing in June where
they can have everybody go and you know
I think the NFL the NFL does this I
think that Super Bowl right yeah
the NFL awards and all and watches I
don't anyone really pays attention to
this because again it happens much later
I don't really get why we're doing this
especially they go through the
postseason and the analysis all
defensive teams and the all-rookie teams
and the all MPA teams like they used to
but they don't announce the MVP and
pencil player of the year in Rookie of
the Year and Sixth Man of the Year and
they do it now and I don't know I always
liked it when they did it during the
playoffs because hey it was something
for people to talk about it B was always
cool when they handed it out before a
game it's playoffs I got I thought it
was a neat thing that they did so to
your point now it's becomes kind of this
afterthought it happens in late June and
you know I would like to find a way you
know and it'd be nice that they could
find a way to change us to where you
know say they did it right after the
regular
and it was like the Friday before the
playoffs starting on Monday or something
that would be I think a better way to do
it but to your point at this point no
one's really paying attention this will
kind of happen and everyone will just
kind of shrug here's the other thing I'm
that get off my lawn guy today I've been
saying for years now and maybe if the
Commissioner comes on the show I can
share it with him we need to stop doing
two guards two forwards in the center
for the all-nba because there's so much
money at stake Kemba Walker would not
have qualified for a supermax if you
just said you know everybody's position
list now Tim why are we archaic in
looking at the all-nba teams that two
guards and to four you know I always
bring up Rudy Gobert you know he's a
nice player but he's not one of the top
15 players in the league and here he is
you know he's probably gonna get a
supermax deal because he's on the first
second third team all-nba as any is
there any uproar over this or mind the
only guy well for one thing I think you
could get Adam silver on the show so you
could probably get him on and ask them
feel confident about that all right no
but in all seriousness I there are there
are people who agree with you and think
that it's crazy that it's not just
picking 15 guys I personally am okay
with the way it's set up now you know I
the way I look at it you know over the
course of the NBA of everyday history
the all-nba teams have always been set
up with two guards two fours in the
center and I personally kind of like
that if you go across the span of the
league but to me that's always the thing
that you know somebody who votes on
these awards that's always the thing
that I care the most about because I
think when you look at the course of the
history of the league that's a good what
you can look back it's like the 1968
season and you can kind of see who the
best players are and I don't mind
breaking down by position I mean to your
point about the Supermax I do think that
it is it is a problem that say Kemba
Walker makes 30ml NBA now he qualifies
for the Supermax but I think that's more
of a issue of that rule being hastily
control not hastily constructed but that
rule has some flaws that could change
and I would rather change the flaws in
the rules and change this but look if
you can told me that but if you told me
that next year right we just voted on
all-nba and it was you pick five guys
the first team five guys for second team
and five grasper team I think that'd be
fine but for me I like to go through it
and see all right like this year there
were you know five fours are really good
right there was Kevin Durant be honest
why Leonard no LeBron and somebody else
I can't take it right now and I like to
go through and break down oh and Paul
George is the other one you know it's
it's fun for me to sit there and go
alright who do I think was who do I
think worth two best forwards this year
and really like sit down and break it
down and figure out who it is so I don't
mind going through and doing it that way
I think it's a good way to delineate who
was the best throughout the league but
again I think your point is valid and if
it did change and get set up that way I
don't think it would be a bad thing
either final 30 seconds give me your hot
free agent prediction that in two weeks
will come true my hot free agent
prediction I think my eyeliner is going
to stay in Toronto he has the medical
staff the coaching staff the front
office of all herbs trust there I was
the season went as well as it could of
we one-year deal Tim which I've been
saying I think that seems like the
option or one plus one or do you think
he's gonna sign a five-year deal it's
really hard to say I mean there has been
some chatter about him signing a
short-term deal and Reese I and either
resigning they're leaving I could see
that going either way just based off
what he decides to do because again we
just saw Kevin Durant and klay Thompson
get hurt the last two games the NBA
Finals right does that change the
calculus for some of these guys with me
watch on it's short-term I'm not sure
you know lost it wait and find out Jim
thank you and have fun over the next
couple of weeks I will I will do my best
thanks guys that's Tim Bon Temps the NBA
writer for ESPN for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on be our live
or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]